why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so Franklin Richards first appears in
Fantastic 4 Annual issue number six in
1968 and just from a reader's
perspective I really don't think this
story is too well written and the reason
why is because there are some things
that are left open there are some
questions that are simply not answered
and while the answers could have been
given to us they're simply not and we
just have to kind of accept them as
being true but what we see as the comic
opens up is that Reed Richards is hard
at work trying to find some way to save
Susan storm and the reason for this is
because Susan storm is currently
pregnant and she is approaching the
hours in which she will begin to give
birth but the problem here is that the
cosmic radiation that had given her Reed
Richards Johnny Storm and The Thing
their respective Powers is still a large
part of her body and because of this
it's entirely possible that this Cosmic
radiation could result in the death of
both Susan storm and the unborn baby now
we don't know why we don't know why it
would result in the death of either of
these two individuals we're simply just
told that it will and for the most part
in this comic we're not really given any
resolution as to how that might happen
we simply just have to accept it and uh
and move on from there what we see is
that Reed Richards comes to the
realization that the only way for him to
save Susan storm and the unborn baby is
to uh gather an article or I'm sorry to
uh capture an artifact from the Negative
Zone but what this artifact is is
something that we don't really know Reed
Richard simply says that he needs to
gain antimatter and antimatter for
whatever reason will combat the cosmic
radiation within the body of Susan storm
and presumably save both her and the
unborn baby but what we see going on
here is that the thing in Johnny Storm
refused to let Reed Richards go by
himself due to the fact that the
negative zone is such a dangerous place
and the last time that Reed Richards had
mounted an incursion into the Negative
Zone it had almost gotten killed from
here we see that Reed Richards Johnny
Storm and the and the Ben Grim are in
the negative Zone they've transitioned
the barrier and are now attempting to
find some method to uh cure Susan storm
of whatever ailment could presumably
kill her and the unborn baby but what we
also see going on here is that the
Negative Zone has been met by the
arrival of annihilist now this is the
first time that we actually see anilis
in Marvel Comics and annihilist is of
course the uh main villain I guess or
the main um protagonist in the uh
Annihilation storyline and all
annihilist really seeks to do is destroy
everything he really just seeks to
eliminate all life and that's what he's
done so far in the negative zone for a
large majority of the Negative Zone he's
eradicated all life and so for the most
part uh annihilist and maybe a few
forces are really the only people left
but what we see is that as Reed Richards
and Johnny Storm make their way through
the Negative Zone they come across a
portion of the Negative Zone which
houses annihilus and his Cosmic control
rod and the cosmic control rod serves a
purpose of granting its wielder virtual
immortality as well as the ability to
manipulate uh objects or matter on the
molecular scale and what we see is that
Reed Richards Johnny Storm and Ben Grim
after a conflict between anil's forces
and themselves they're able to capture
the cosmic control rod and transport
themselves back to the planet Earth from
here we see that of course uh Susan
storm is able to give birth to the baby
after Reed Richards had done whatever it
was that he needed to do in order to
ensure that she was able to give birth
and we see that Reed Richards is holding
Franklin Richards and this is the very
first time that we will ever see
Franklin Richards in Marvel Comics now
one thing I would like for you to keep
in the back of your head is the
discussion that we had in uh the video
the first video as the leadup to
Franklin Richards because these elements
are going to become very important as we
watch the progression of not just Marvel
Comics but Franklin Richard's character
throughout the Marvel publication
history up until the current
date
so between Fantastic 4 Annual issue
number six and 1968 and Fantastic 4
issue number
245 what we see going on here is that
for the most part Franklin Richards is
simply a background character there
really isn't too much going on with him
he of course is I guess handed over to
agath the Harkness By the Fantastic 4
not in the sense that they give him away
but in the sense that they they uh allow
her to be somewhat of a caretaker for
him in the sense that she simply just
monitors him keeps an eye on him and of
course due to the fact that he has the
mutant ability to warp reality um that
she's able to more or less try to keep
him quelled but at this point Franklin
Richards hasn't really demonstrated the
uh powers that he possesses they flare
up from time to time but nothing of any
real substance but with Fantastic 4
issue number 245 we see for the most
part the first time in which Franklin
Richard's Powers swell up to such a
degree that He makes himself a virtually
omnipotent character and what we see in
Fantastic 4 ISS number 245 is that Susan
storm has been spending the day
associating with a friend of hers but
when she arrives back to the backer
building what she sees is that for the
most part the building seems to be
entirely empty that no one really seems
to be there there's uh really no
discussion no talking and the the area
really seems for the most part to be
dead she discovers the body of Reed
Richards but Reed Richards isn't dead
what's actually happened is that Reed
Richards mind appears to have been shut
down and Reed Richards of course uh
stretched out along a hallways which
really indicates that he had been
fighting somebody or or somehow been
engaged in a conflict in such a way that
it required the use of his powers Susan
storm is continuing to investigate the
backer building and she comes across an
individual a tall blonde man who is
holding Johnny Storm by the neck now
what's really interesting here is that
this is the plasma form of Johnny Storm
which is physically the most powerful
form that Johnny Johnny Storm has now
this is not to be confused with Johnny
Storm's Nova blast Johnny Storm does
have a move called the Nova blast which
in effect
is a massive detonation that can destroy
a multitude of different things but the
fact that this individual is able to
hold Johnny Storm while Johnny Storm is
in his plasma form and this individual
is sustaining no injury of any kind and
is able to keep Johnny Storm from
escaping seems to be quite a uh
incredible feat in and of itself we see
this individual talking to Johnny Storm
and what he tells Johnny Storm is that
Johnny has the secrets to or has the
answer to whatever question it is this
individual is looking for and and he
begins to forcefully probe the mind of
Johnny Storm when he learns that Johnny
Storm does not have the answers he seeks
he simply discards the unconscious body
of Johnny Storm from here we see that
Susan storm who has been invisible in
watching this uh incident take place is
immediately detected by this blonde man
and again this is simply another
instance of this individual
demonstrating how powerful he is and the
reason why is because with the exception
of telepaths of the highest order or
individuals who exist on a cosmic level
and can detect
uh changes and the I guess molecular
area around them not very many people
can actually detect Susan storm when she
is invisible when Susan storm is
detected she immediately makes a run for
it and we see this blonde individual
chasing after her he tells her that she
may have the answers that he seeks and
that it's futile to attempt to get away
we see that as Susan storm is running
from room to room that this individual
is in effect uh remaking the walls of
the building in order to allow him to
pass through and this is simply again
another demonstration of the vast power
that this individual has that he can
simply just alter the molecular
structure of inanimate objects to suit
his needs we see that Susan storm comes
across uh the apartment of Ben grim and
the apartment appears to have suffered
some sort of damage or some sort of
violent action whereby uh an explosion
appears to have taken place in addition
she's unable to find Franklin Richards
who of course had been located in this
area prior to her leaving the backer
building earlier in the day and so she
begins to panic for fear of the fact
that something may have happened to her
son from here we see that ultimately
Susan storm comes into conflict she is
uh for the most part apprehended by this
blonde individual but that the remaining
members of the Fantastic Four whose
conscious Minds have been restored come
to her Aid and what we learn here is
that this individual uh is in fact
Franklin Richards that Franklin Richards
had been given a Rubik's Cube by Ben
grim and Ben Grim had asked him if he
could Solve IT Franklin Richards uh due
to his Youth and his inability to solve
complex puzzles was unable to solve the
Rubik's Cube so in response he simply
just willed it to be solved at that
point he heard a voice on the television
say when are you going to grow up and
then subconsciously Franklin Richards uh
transformed himself into a full-grown
man now the other thing to bear in mind
here is that while prior to this
Franklin Richards had demonstrated
subconsciously maybe a bit of his powers
here and there this is an instance
whereby Franklin Richards has full
possession of his abilities and that
while this individual is a child as far
as his mind goes in the body of a grown
man he is still for the most part quite
Adept in being able to use his abilities
but what we see is that the last Act of
this individual before he reverts
himself back into his childlike form
after realizing what had happened is
that he offers to transform Ben Grim
back into his previous state and what
had happened previously is that Reed
Richards had attempted to find some way
to make Ben Grim human again and
Franklin Richard tells Ben Grim that he
can make him look human and he begins to
probe the mind of Ben Grim at that point
he telepathically says something to read
Richards and Reed Richards simply tells
Franklin Richards do whatever it is you
feel you need to do from here we see
what appears to be more or less a bright
light and then we see that Franklin
Richards is back in his childlike State
and that Ben Grim is back in his uh
Rocky State we see that of course Bening
Grim asks Reed Richards why it was that
he hadn't been transported or
transformed back into a human again and
Reed Richards says that Franklin
Richards was unable to do this that he
was not able to transform him back into
his normal human self that he had to
transform him back into his previous
state whereby he hadn't been uh altered
by Reed Richards but what we see is that
uh as Ben Grim walks away with his blind
girlfriend Alicia that Susan storm asks
Reed Richards isn't uh Franklin Richards
able to do pretty much anything and
there was really no reason why he could
not have set Ben Grim back to being
human again again Reed Richards replies
that when Franklin Richards was talking
to him telepathically Franklin Richards
discovered that Ben Grim's biggest fear
is that if he ever were to turn back
into a human again that Alicia who was
blind would fall out of love with him
because she's no longer the man that he
knows and so when Franklin Richards
detected this Franklin Richards wanted
to ensure that Ben Grim would stay happy
and so he gave him gave him back his
previous rock formation now from this
point going forward in the Marvel Comics
when it comes to Franklin Richards I
would again ask you to pay very close
attention to the things that go on to
the things that happen and I would like
you to pay very close attention to the
Fantastic 4 as well and other
superheroes that come into contact with
Franklin Richards and again if you will
refer back to our discussion about uh
the silver and golden age of comics I
think that by this point you may have
noticed something relatively interesting
something that I think is pretty pivotal
and is really the root of one of the
biggest questions in Marvel Comics that
question being why is it that comic book
characters don't
[Music]
age so from Fantastic 4 issue number 376
up until the Future Foundation storyline
Franklin Richards will play a very
important role in a multitude of
storylines the most notable of which is
the story of onslaught and during the
story of onslaught what we had learned
is that the frustration that Charles
Xavier had been experiencing over
Humanity's refusal to peacefully coexist
with mutants and Magneto's hatred for
Humanity had combined into a very
powerful psychic entity and this entity
was n Unstoppable for quite some time
and especially so after it had absorbed
the Consciousness or the powers of
Franklin Richards and Nate gray X-Men
but what we saw over the course of the
onslaught storyline was that through a
combination of the actions of the
Incredible Hulk Bruce Banner and
the X-Men the Avengers and and the
Fantastic 4 and various other
superheroes that Onslaught was thwarted
but in the process in order to ensure
his defeat virtually all of the
non-mutant superheroes had jumped into
the the spiritual or I guess the energy
based body of onslaught and were
presumed to have been killed but what we
actually learned here was that the uh
child version uh Franklin Richards had
subconsciously brought them all Back to
Life by creating a separate universe and
this universe was called The Heroes
Reborn universe and during this hero
Heroes Reborn storyline we're taught a
few things or told a few things by
Marvel one of the first things we learn
is that this is a universe that was
created by Franklin Richards but it was
done subconsciously Franklin Richards
didn't realize that he had actually done
this what we also learn is that the
Universe exists inside of a blue object
about the size of a blue bowling ball
that Franklin Richards carries with him
everywhere he goes again because this is
subconscious Franklin Richards doesn't
understand what this blue ball is or
what it means he just simply knows that
he needs to hold on to it and in the
Heroes Reborn storyline we more or less
get a reboot of sorts for the Marvel
characters that supposedly died during
the onslaught storyline but what we also
see taking place is that a member of the
celestial host appears to Franklin
Richards in the form of a human and
tells Franklin Richards that because of
his actions in creating the hero's
reborn universe that he has caught the
attention of the celestials and the
celestials are arriving to force
Franklin Richards to make a choice
either Franklin Richards can choose to
allow the hero's reborn Universe to
exist and Destroy his own Earth 616
universe or he can destroy the Heroes
Reborn universe and keep the Earth 616
Universe alive and over the course of
the Heroes Reborn story line what we
learned is that Franklin Richards
chooses to keep the Earth 616 universe
and so all the superheroes that were in
in existence or had been housed within
the hero's reborn Universe were brought
back to the Earth 616 Universe by
Franklin Richards and then restored to
their previous state now again at this
point despite the fact that his actions
are subconscious Franklin Richards again
demonstrates to us that he has powers
that are virtually unrivaled by anybody
within the Marvel Universe but again
Franklin Richards makes a very big
decision here and I hope you've caught
it that Franklin Richards had in effect
redcon Marvel superheroes that he has
adjusted the histories of Marvel
Superheroes he has in effect change
their stories entirely and what we will
see as we move forward with this
discussion especially when we get into
the Future Foundation is that Franklin
Richards will do this time and time
again but this is the power that's being
demonstrated from the mind of a child
and what I would like you to do here is
to compare Franklin Richards to the
Marvel Comics community that is to say
the writers and the artists at Marvel
Comics to a lot of the storylines that
you've read in Marvel Comics and to ask
yourself this question what similarity
does Franklin Richards have with the
storylines and the retconning events
that go on in Marvel
[Music]
Comics so the Future Foundation
storyline of the Fantastic 4 which began
in Fantastic 4 issue number
579 is one of my favorite stories in the
Fantastic 4 and the reason for this is
because for the most part this will
Chronicle read Richard's attempt to
solve everything and Reed Richards will
in fact encounter a group called the
Council of Richards which exists in this
sort of Nexus that is to say this in
between area where all universes meet
and the Council of Reed Richards or the
Council of reeds as they call themselves
are a combination of multiple Reed
Richards from multiple universes and
that each of these versions of Reed
Richards varies from the other in the
sense that one version of Reed Richards
has Johnny Storm's Powers one version of
Reed Richards has uh Susan Storm's
Powers another version of Reed Richards
is a portal to all other universes they
vary depending on uh that universe that
scale of that universe and what it was
that resulted in Reed Richards becoming
that way but the intention of these uh
these multiple reads are to effectively
solve all the problems in the Marvel
Multiverse and their actions result in
the attention of the group of celestials
from an alternate universe and the
celestials from this universe have an
effect grown mad they've grown insane
due to the fact that they've began to
view themselves as the gods of that
universe and that they should not only
be worshiped by the inhabitants of that
universe but they should be they should
be worshiped by inhabitants of all
universes what we see is that one of the
versions of Reed Richards which hails
from this universe that has the Mad
version of the celestials had previously
been kidnapped by the celestials and it
had his mind read by the celestials at
which point the celestials learned about
these Council of Reed Richards when the
Council of Reed Richards was invaded by
the celestials the Reed Richards from
the earth 616 Universe had fled but what
we had also learned is that of all these
Reed Richards that our version the Earth
616 version of Reed Richards is the only
one who had refused to give up his
family now while this is taking place we
see that at the backer building while
these celestials are on their way that
an individual a older blonde man enters
the backer building undetected until the
sensors begin to go off and no one quite
knows how he was able to enter the
Fantastic Four attempt to intercept him
but we see that he puts up a force field
that is simply impenetrable by anybody
he speaks to Franklin richers by virtue
of more or less waking up his powers and
at the end we see that what's going on
here is that Franklin Richards is in
fact under his blanket and is creating a
universe in the palm of his hands from
this point we fast forward over a series
of events and we end up at this conflict
whereby the Mad celestials have arrived
on the planet Earth we see that of
course Reed Richards for the most part
is able to uh summon galatis not
directly but simply by enticing galatis
to the planet Earth Galactus encounters
the mad celestials and the celestials
combine themselves into one being and
are able to swiftly thwart galatis at
this point Galactus is not necessarily
dead Galactus is simply just in a very
weaken State due to the amount of energy
that he's expended fighting the
celestials and is unable to continue any
further the celestials then begin to
split apart and of course begin to fight
the Fantastic Four and over the course
of their conflict with the Fantastic
Four we see that virtually everybody is
defeated with the exception of um of
Susan storm and Susan storm is able to
in effect try to hold her own by
blocking the attacks of the celestials
but at the moment in which she is in
effect going to be defeated and
presumably killed that the future adult
versions of Franklin Richards and his
sister Valeria Richards appear now this
is a really interesting part of the
comic and the reason why this is one of
my my favorite parts of the uh Future
Foundation event is because this is when
we see that Franklin Richards makes
galatis his Herald what we had learned
from Nathaniel Richard who is currently
with the Fantastic Four is that when
Reed Richards had uh joined the Council
of reeds and when he had refused to
abandon his family that by virtue of
being the only person who did that he
set forward a series of events that
would result in Franklin Richards
traveling into the past because by
refusing to abandon his family he had
begun to spend time with his family he
had begun to associate with his family
and given his family the kind of
attention and the kind of devotion that
they were in desperate need of by virtue
of this Franklin Richards has traveled
into the past to try to keep rid
Richards from being killed by the
celestial host which had happened in
Franklin Richards future what we see is
that when Franklin Richards of the
future had spoken with his younger self
prior to this conflict that he had told
his younger self to Simply hold all the
energy that he would gain over this time
that all the energy that he would
normally use needs to Simply Be uh
stored more or less and that Franklin
Richards would know what to do when the
time came at this point Franklin
Richards uses these energies to revive
galatis and then to supercharge
galactus's Powers when the celestials
arrive they are greeted by both Franklin
Richards and his Herald galatis over the
course of the conflict which is uh
sheerly devastating in terms of the
amount of Destruction that's being
wrought and simply just on a scale that
virtually no one other than galatis and
Franklin Richards can possibly
comprehend hand that ultimately Franklin
Richards is successful although it's
presumed that he had died in reality he
had actually survived and this survival
is revealed to them by galatis and we
see that for the most part this version
of Franklin Richards as he is being
shown to us is an individual who is so
astronomically powerful that he is in
effect on par with the highest order of
celestials the highest order of cosmic
entities in the Marvel universe as and
is in effect at this very moment on the
level of a
[Music]
God so what we see going on here as we
look at Franklin Richards and the bigger
picture is that Franklin Richards
represents Marvel on multiple levels for
one Franklin Richards is a universal
constant meaning that because of the
powers that he possesses he is on par
with some of the highest orders of
cosmic entities in Marvel Comics he is
in fact the most powerful Earthbound
Superhero in Marvel Comics but what we
also see is that Franklin Richards is a
comic book constant meaning that uh he
is a character that will always be part
of the comic book scene and the reason
why is because Franklin Richards is for
the most part a representation of Marvel
Comics he's a representation of what it
means to be a writer or an editor and
the reason why is because what we see
with Franklin Richards going on in comic
books is that during the golden and age
of Comics comic books followed the
current trends follow comic books
reflected the current time the current
events and characters grew and
characters got older but then Franklin
Richards came along and that stopped
characters stopped getting older for the
most part the only characters that
really really grew when it came to
Marvel Comics or really got older in
terms of them just becoming older people
were individuals that for the most part
never really came into contact with
Franklin Richards and so for the for the
most part that is pretty much everybody
in The Avengers that is the Fantastic
Four that is a majority of the X-Men and
it's only the Lesser known Publications
or for the most part the characters you
don't see very often that are the ones
that grow older now recent events
especially considering original sin and
Nick Fury in Marvel Comics have adjusted
this they have reflected the fact that
this isn't 100%
true but what's really interesting here
is that aside from the age of characters
aside from characters not growing older
Franklin Richards represents the
establishment he represents the status
quo and what I mean by this is in the
example of onslaught and the example of
of a braus who who of course was the
result of Galactus being killed and jump
an individual that jumped from Universe
to Universe killing various
galacti abraxis was destroyed by virtue
of Franklin Richards restoring galatis
and Reed Richards using the ultimate
nullifier but this is a reflection of
the status quo that Marvel maintains
that Marvel has a set standard when it
comes to superheroes marvel has a set
standard when it comes to storylines and
groups and that those will always be
there that when an event comes along
that changes things irrevocably or could
potentially change things irrevocably
that Franklin Richards comes along by
virtue of the writers and editors at
Marvel Comics and stops it he sets
things back to the way they were
supposed to be and this could be
construed as a good or a bad thing some
people may look at it and say this is an
inherently bad thing because it does not
allow characters to progress we don't
get to see other versions of the
Fantastic 4 the Fantastic 4 are always
Susan storm Reed Richards Johnny Storm
and the thing we don't get to see the
next generation of the Fantastic 4 and
they look at characters like Spider-Man
and they look at groups like The X-Men
and of course they see and continue to
believe the same thing and this I would
say is the most important part of
Franklin Richards when it comes to
Marvel Comics the fact that Franklin
Richards as a child does not want to see
the world change and so the argument
that's being produced here is that
Franklin Richards in effect controls the
Marvel Universe the only people that age
are the people that Franklin Richards is
okay with aging the only people who
don't age are the ones that Franklin
Richards doesn't want to lose over time
Franklin Richards likes the world the
way it is and so when a circumstance
comes along that jeopardizes that
Franklin Richards changes things back
and this is a reflection of again the
status quo that we've seen Marvel Comics
we of course saw the Days of Future Past
we saw Heroes Reborn Heroes return we
saw a lot of these events take place in
Marvel Comics and over time the events
were retconed or almost immediately they
were retconned and the status quo was
reinstated and then things began again
and again this is really interesting
here because I think that a large
portion of people look at Franklin
Richards and they see him as simply just
a child with an incredible amount of
power when in reality while he may have
that he is much more than that because
he represents Marvel Comics as a whole
He represents Marvel Comics ideologies
as a whole and he represents the fact
that at the end of the day that Marvel
is very reluctant to move on from the
status quo that's been presented to us
and that ever since
1968 that characters have for the most
part never moved forward never Advanced
and that neither has Marvel comics with
that being said I'm going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys
[Music]
peace